[Music]
thank you everyone
Suroosh and let's get it started
I'm gonna focus on cube flow pipelines
it is our product for helping developers
go from prototyping to a real production
system so the agenda for today's I'm
gonna give you an overview of our
motivation and our approach for how we
build IQ for pipelines and then I'm
gonna give you some of the examples of
the problems that inspired to pool
pipelines and what you heard from the
customers and their needs and last I
will show you some of the features that
queue for pipelines has currently and
how you can use it so let's go through
the motivation first so if you have
worked on machine learning deployments
before you know that building deploying
ml modules is hard and costly in order
to go end-to-end from grabbing the data
to having the model serving and so on
there is much more than just building
the model so the problems that we see
today in AI are at least three of them
that we are trying to tackle is
deployment where there are different
solutions for different frameworks and
each cloud provider might want to might
want you to use their solution for a
specific AI problem and then when you
want to go to on-prem or switch between
clouds they usually break or you're not
even supported so the next one is
finding talent and really using the
talents time effectively ml expertise is
not easy to come by
you want to really use their ml expert
time as efficiently as possible
and lastly the echo system is the
problem with ecosystem is that it is
difficult to find and reuse what is out
there
if you know that like a new model came
out for image processing for example and
you want to grab that model and use it
in your production system finding it and
using it in your production system takes
a lot of effort so our solution to these
problems
it is cube flow reusable pipelines and
AI hub so I'm going to go through these
one by one so what is cube flow it is
built on top of kubernetes to let you
train your machine learning models it
has support for pi torch tensorflow
extra boost and a lot of other popular
frameworks
it also takes care of serving and so on
so it is more end-to-end it has support
for GPU and like multi node training so
it can scale up or down depending on
your problem and you can run it on any
query in this pipeline covering these
deployments so if you have your own
cluster at your company you don't want
to use TCP great if you have a queries
deployment you can install quick cube
flow on top of it but there is also DCP
support next is reusable pipelines the
goal is basically enabling an engineer
or a machine learning expert to not
waste time on rebuilding and reinventing
everything from scratch but picking the
pieces that were built before and really
just reusing it and building it what
they care about
so discoverability of like these
reusable pipelines is the problem and AI
hub tries to tackle that area hub is the
place where it is a product that Google
has built it you can search for the type
of problem you're trying to solve and
find solutions that are already built
for that type of problem and very easily
built your pipeline around those so you
can stitch them together and build your
pipeline there it is really fast and
easy to use it's there's a one-click
install installation for queue flow on
your CP so if you found something that
you want to use from the IAI hub you can
easily deploy it on your GCP account
basically and there is also enterprise
level sharing so what I mean is that
within your company if you have built
something that is interesting to other
teams other employees of the company you
can share that solution with the rest of
the company and also if you want to
share it publicly you can also say I
want to share this publicly so everyone
can use it so next I'm going to talk
about the type of problems that inspired
tube flow pipelines let's say you have a
your problem that you're trying to solve
you figure out what where you can gather
the data types that you care about for
this type of problem you create your CSV
file you do your pre-processing of that
file and have your Python for
pre-processing and then you have another
Python file for like training the model
and it will produce a model file and
you're trying to figure out how do you
go from that model file to something you
can have in the production and
soon you will see there is more to that
like once you go beyond the ml model you
might want to look at how the model
quality changes over time if you just
put the model out is the model still as
performant as it was when you first
deploy so there's monitoring and then
you think about how can I continuously
deploy this model so with the fresh data
that is coming in I want to create a new
model push that new model to the
production how do I mind to new versions
of the model how do i scale the serving
of the model so that like if there's a
new traffic coming in I can easily
respond to that when when the new data
is coming in you want to verify the new
data so they're like if there's a
regression somewhere in the pipeline
that produces that input data you want
to be able to cache that so as you look
into it it can grow to really a hard
problem so this is a tweet that talks
about like she developed the model in
three weeks but going to production
system took almost a year so what we
hear from customers from different
companies is that using these tools for
workflow management for pipeline
management that are not built for
machine learning they have trouble
applying it to machine learning because
they're machine learning specific things
for example you care about metrics in
machine learning for each model that can
be different you to care about
experimenting with different hyper
parameters and different model versions
are different and there are things that
are very specific to machine learning
that you can't just use any pipeline
management system and if you don't have
any pipeline management system then your
models might be working today but as the
data changes and the user
a viewer changes the models become a
still and updating the model might take
many many steps you might have to run
few jobs manually to grab the data and
like train the model and test make sure
it is actually performing as we expect
and then push it to production and if
you want to do it every week it is a lot
of overhead
and lastly experimentation of different
hyper parameters is difficult like there
is a no good way of tracking what was
the hype around it that was used for
this model so if in the future like in a
month from the time that the model was
trained you want to look back and see
how was this model train tracking that
and be able to reproduce the same model
or change the model is difficult and
that these are the kind of problem that
the customers had so that is why we will
cube for pipelines so next I'll give you
an overview of the cue flow pipelines
the features it has the first piece of
it is orchestrating your system
basically in your pipeline you will have
different components that are
responsible for pre-processing here or
transforming training and so on and
cupolo pipeline is responsible for
making sure that the dependencies are
met and it will execute the containers
in the right order and takes care of
distribution of them you can also take a
look at the trainer job and look at
matrix that it provides so if you click
on the trainer you can see the RFC
Trevor in this case that the trainer was
providing if it was a tensorflow job it
will have a tensor board if you have
used tensor flow before but if it is
like extra boost model it will have its
own visualization of its matrix you can
also look at the logs during training if
there was any like errors or something
you can take a look here and the
configuration that was used for the
trainer so as I said a pipeline is
basically a set of tasks and all tasks
and we use containers to encapsulate all
it needs to run make the code portable
and repeatable a task it can be run on a
single machine or a distributed fashion
and you float take care of that and
there is a Python SDK that lets you
specify the steps that your pipeline is
to run and the dependencies between the
different steps and it provides a way
for you to say what are the parameters
to these pipelines an example of a
parameter to a pipeline can be like
hyper parameters for learning rate for
learning rate or for the optimizer to
use or it can be the input files that
you want to process or what is the
column in your CSV file that has the
labeling so it will be easier to reuse
if you parameterize it here's an example
of a jupiter notebook that you have
input your pipeline here there is
pre-processing training and analysis and
prediction and deploy steps and it is
just as easy as like few lines of Python
code to build a pipeline and run it on a
cube
Krauser next is how you reliably
experiment and you can rapidly change
and develop your model so the cycle for
experimentation is basically that you
run you pick some high parameters that
you want to try let's say I want to try
103 is 200 trees and so on and you start
you submit a bunch of runs you wait for
the results you get some outputs out of
those results and now you want to look
what which one of these runs had the
best result and maybe clone the best one
modified and running again with
different configuration maybe slightly
differently and experiment and improve
your model so this is the UI for
tracking your models you can see that
all the runs are grouped by their
experiments so if you're experimenting
with like an image model and like here
there's a FMA experiment extra boost
rating experiment and they can have
multiple runs and these are previous
runs that finished and there is a
currently running job here and you can
easily clone an existing run so you open
one of the runs you see that it has a
good our receipt you can click on the
clone here or look at the configuration
and create a copy of it and when you
create a copy of it it will fill up the
parameters that you provided but you can
update the parameters so you say here
instead of like number of trees 200 you
want 300 trees this time and it is just
as easy to iterate on your model
so comparing between ones is very easy
it will give you basically for an
experiment you will see a list of
metrics and you can compare different
runs and how they performed and if you
want to dig deeper into each of these
you can select let's say like three of
them and click on compare runs and that
way you'll get a deep dive on those
three how did they compare against each
other yeah you get the metrics AUC and
so on the last piece of the puzzle was
sharing and reusing components so as we
said we want to reuse and compose
instead of array implementing and
reinventing everything so in this
example that we saw previously these
steps are actually coming from AI hub so
once you found the right component that
does what you care about calling it in
your pipeline is as easy as just calling
the function in your Python code and we
find the containers that needs to run as
part of this AI hub component and we'll
add it to your pipeline basically yeah
that's all there is any questions now
[Applause]
there is a combination of all right so
the question was what is the back end
that this is implemented in it is a
combination of so kubernetes itself and
on top of it so there is some go on
Python and obviously like the components
that you call it can be any language and
also they can call other cloud services
so within your code you can have a
component that uses data prog or data
flow for this route data processing or
like it can use bigquery and all that
yeah so like you don't have to use
Python or bill or anything as long as
you have your code in the container you
can run it as part of this pipeline any
other questions
okay yep yeah so there is there is some
code that basically takes care of
container izing your notebook so if your
model is in your notebook it will look
at your state of whatever like have you
uploaded in your Python and takes a
snapshot of that and put it in a
container so you can run it remotely on
a distributed system yeah
basically there is a very there's a
versioning for models is that the
question yeah and like you can go back
to a version of the model and see how
was it produced and what was the
configuration for that version
the
so yeah okay so happy primary tuning is
that the question so the question is is
there a way to basically try variations
of different parameters and
automatically find the best parameter
settings right is that yeah so there is
a there is a like a Khatib library I
believe that for hydropower and tuning
in a cube flow I haven't used it
personally but you can it provides a way
to say like these are my favorite
parameters this is the space that you
are searching for and it will do the
automatic search for parameters
basically if you'll not do it like a
linear sweep of the parameter but it
will try different experiments and
different other parameter values and
pick the best one with you
so the question is let me see if I can
understand the question right you have
different sets of input and you want to
try them all and see which one which set
of inputs provide the best model there
were minimum set of the so you can treat
that as a hyper parameter to the model
so like you provide all the sets to the
model and then the hyper parameter that
says how many of these use during
training for example and it can be one
two three four five if you have five
data sets and see which one provides the
best model or see all of them and see
which one is acceptable quality for you
for example does that make sense
Oh
so let me so let me go back a little bit
these are components so component is
when you have already developed your
your Python code and you have built a
container and you expose it as a
component to a pipeline and so there is
support for preed containerized code so
like if you have built your docker
container somewhere else you can use it
in pipelines if you have your Python
code somewhere else in this Jupiter
notebook you can say I create a
container from that and then create a
component that calls that container and
that also works so when you look at this
pipeline these are not there is no way
to edit this right now like you can edit
it at this stage because it is running
this is showing like a result of a run
anything happens before you create a
pipeline so you you you write your
pipeline that's a cause a bunch of
containers and so on and when you run it
through I get that nice graph really
[Music]
yeah yep
[Music]
yeah so like the API supports so
pre-processing is a stage here and
pre-processing has that output so it can
provide a single output or a list of
outputs you can I don't know if it is
visible but basically a component can
have a list of outputs and it can be
used in the future steps of like other
steps in the pipeline so pre-processing
takes some input and produces some
output and training takes it out to the
front pre-processing and so on okay so
you're passing the here you can see
example of like a Google storage path as
like one of the inputs and the output of
the each component will create a temp
directory on cloud India
so the cupola will have different like
deployment environments and each
environment can say like this is how you
create a job and how do you create a
temporary and so on so even on Prem you
don't have to use GS you can using so in
here we don't have any like containers
here this is just using some components
that are predefined and these components
if you look at the definition of them
some of them are coming from a hub but
the ones that are not coming from a hub
are defined in the same I don't know if
I have any example of that in the slides
let me quickly go back see if there's
ink but basically you will say this is a
container name and how do you specify
yeah like this is open-source by the way
you can go through the examples there
are some samples for different like
extra boost transfer flow and so on
and I encourage everyone to take a look
at the Jupiter notebooks there in the
notebooks they're using containers so
you'll see some example of that so there
are four serving their components that
are in charge of serving and they are
more specific so we have developed
serving stack for extra boost module and
tensorflow module and I believe by
torching is coming I don't know exactly
where it is but basically there are
reusable components for serving as well
and you can say this is a deploy for
tensorflow
so it will assume that the input is a
tensor flow model but there is a deploys
for extra boost and so on so you can say
deploy this model and is that answering
good question
sorry okay so the the difference here is
that there is no like internal format
here there is there are components that
provide like extra boost models and
there are components that servic service
models so you can basically a build your
pipeline stitching these together so
when so there is a validation of the
models for example we can say if the
model quality is not as good as
yesterday or compared to yesterday the
model quality is dropping by this much
don't push the production a regression
like a unit tests are not supported but
some sort of like continues automated
pushing and validation of the model is
support
so the question is are we in production
and do we have a production roadmap so
currently it is an open source project
built mostly by Google but there are
partners that are for putting components
in the AI hub and so on so you can use
it on Prem or on Google Cloud or
anywhere you have kubernetes but we are
planning to do a hosted service for this
as well it will be just the managed
service but same features so
yeah yeah data Bert's has something
similar called ml flow
I have not isn't I guess is it supposed
to like be end-to-end and so on okay
this is also Noddin one end at how like
yes sir
so q ploy is a bit older but true
pipelines is next iteration on that and
it focuses and reusable pipelines and AI
hub and so on so that is relatively like
less than a year or I will say
it's not for deployment it was for
tracking
you know question okay no I thought you
got
all right I think that's that's it
[Applause]
[Music]